Au commencement,
il n'y avait rien.
Presque rien.
Rien que Babos.
Babos était un dieu
qui avait une sainte horreur
de la solitude et de l'obscurité.
Alors,
il décida de créer la lumière.
Puis, comme tout
dieu qui se respecte
et qui s'ennuie
Babos inventa
un monde de mortels
et il créa la Terre.
Sur cette Terre,
il enracina
les premiers mortels,
les arbres.
Il leur donna un vaste
jardin d'Eden au sol fertile,
les plaines du Masai Mara
en Afrique de l'Est.
Dans ce paradis
les arbres se multiplièrent.
Acacia parapluie, goumbi,
chigomier et balsamier formèrent bientôt
un uniforme
ruban de verdure.
Ensemble,
tous les arbres croissaient
les uns à côté des autres.
Enfin presque tous,
sauf le figuier, un solitaire.
Celui-ci avait pris racine
au bord de la rivière Talek qui coulera
quand Babos le voudra.
Il n'avait pas son pareil
et se voyait de loin.
C'était le plus
grand arbre du Masai Mara.
Son tronc avait
six mètres de circonférence.
Il le fallait
pour soutenir un entrelacs
de branches pesant plusieurs tonnes.
Chaque figuier du Masai Mara
avait son propre cycle de fructification.
Seulement, très vite,
Babos se lassa
d'admirer ses plantations.
Cette immobilité l'ennuyait.
Alors, il créa les animaux.
Les animaux pouvaient
se mouvoir, c'était bien plus distrayant.
Babos eu l'idée de leur donner
les plantes immobiles pour se nourrir.
Tous devaient s'en
accommoder sans rechigner.
Tous, sauf un.
Un animal couvert
de poils de la tête aux pieds
à l'exception
des mains et du museau.
Pas de doute,
Babos avait créé
cet animal à son image.
C'était un singe.
Le babouin anubis.
La création de cet être
que Babos voulait parfait fut
toute une histoire,
une histoire à rebondissements.
Babos créa d'abord
un mâle de 20 ans.
Puisqu'il est
le premier, appelons-le Alpha.
Se doutant que comme lui
sa créature ait
horreur de la solitude,
il lui procure sans plus attendre
non pas une
mais plusieurs femelles.
70 centimètres
au garrot, 30 kilos,
Alpha est deux fois
plus imposant que ses compagnes.
Cela ne signifie pas qu'il peut
se prendre pour le patriarche.
Les femelles et leurs petits
forment le noyau de la tribu.
Les mâles sont là
pour les protéger et les féconder
au gré de leur désir.
Ainsi l'a voulu Babos.
Alpha est obligé de partager
avec d'autres, les femelles,
si aimablement
mis à disposition,
notamment avec ces deux-là
Romos et Molosse.
Agés de six et huit ans,
ils cherchent déjà une place
dans la hiérarchie des mâles adultes.
Ce qui augure pour ces babouins
d'une vie politique compliquée.
Nous n'en sommes pas là.
Pour l'heure,
Babos doit consacrer
quelques-unes de ses journées
à inculquer à ses chères
créatures l'art de vivre.
Il leur donne pour lieu
d'habitation principale, un arbre
et pas n'importe lequel,
le géant du Masai Mara,
le figuier.
Ils pourront y dormir, s'y réunir
et surveiller les alentours
Les babouins
semblent apprécier ce dortoir.
Ils ne consentent à le quitter
que pour aller assouvir leur faim.
Au petit matin, le premier
qui sent son estomac le tirailler donne
le signal, les autres suivent.
Dès que les locataires
de la canopée sont partis,
ceux des étages
inférieurs se manifestent.
Les premières à se montrer
sont les fourmis qui mangent
les parties mortes de l'écorce.
Puis le lézard
qui vient réchauffer son sang froid
aux premiers rayons du soleil.
Quelques étages plus bas
un rat a élu domicile
dans le labyrinthe des racines.
Pendant ce temps,
les babouins descendent
le long du lit de la rivière.
Elle est presque sèche
en ce moment, mais ses berges
sont un précieux garde-manger.
Ils y trouvent des bulbes,
des racines, des tubercules,
leur principale source de nourriture.
Les grands se gavent,
les petits gambadent avec insouciance
sachant qu'après avoir bien mangé,
les mamans seront
disposées à leur donner la tétée.
Impressionnantes,
les cornes de la gazelle des roseaux.
Ô combien redoutables
quand elle s'en sert
pour faire fuir un importun.
Pas de danger ici.
Le Masai Mara
est une oasis permanente
ainsi l’a voulu Babos.
Les plantes immobiles
sont assez abondantes et variées
pour que tout habitant
y trouve sa part de nourriture
presque toute l'année.
Pas de compétition
alimentaire non plus
entre les singes
et cet oiseau, le Jaribu.
D'ailleurs,
les babouins vivent en harmonie
avec tous
les végétariens du Masai Mara
Même les mastodontes.
Tout en cherchant leurs pitances,
les babouins ont gagné
la berge opposée de la rivière.
Bien loin de leur arbre dortoir,
ils déambulent dans
de vastes plaines marécageuses
où pâturent
des herbivores de tous acabits.
Pour arracher les herbes
et déterrer les bulbes,
les babouins disposent
de nombreux organes
qu'ils peuvent
utiliser simultanément.
Les doigts, surtout le pouce,
les ongles, les dents, les lèvres.
Ce savoir-faire,
les jeunes l'acquièrent
en singeant les adultes,
cela va de soi.
Ils prennent le temps de déguster,
si bien qu'ils passeront six heures
de cette journée
d'existence à se nourrir.
Il en sera toujours ainsi.
En fin d'après-midi,
Alpha donne le signal du départ.
Fini le festin,
tout le monde regagne le dortoir.
Certain d'avoir
créé un monde parfait,
Babos ne tarde pas à plonger
dans le sommeil du bienheureux.
Sur la Terre,
c'est l'heure du coucher.
La nuit tombe
autour du grand figuier
et tous les membres
de la troupe d'Alpha s'y installent.
Chacun choisit sa branche
et cherche la position
la plus confortable.
Les babouins dorment
environ huit heures par nuit,
par cycle de deux heures.
C'est ce qu'ils ont de mieux
à faire, car comme Babos,
ils ont une sainte
horreur de l'obscurité
et du reste, une très
mauvaise vision nocturne.
Pendant que le gros
de la troupe tombe au sommeil,
les femelles qui sont de corvées
d'allaitement montent la garde.
Jusque-là, tout va encore
très bien pour les babouins.
Voilà qu'un beau matin,
Babos se réveille
avec une furieuse envie
de manger des figues.
Gorgées de soleil,
celles du plus bel arbre
du Masai Mara sont enfin mûres.
Babos les veillent
jalousement depuis fort longtemps
aucun mortel
n'a le droit d'y toucher.
Pour faire respecter cet interdit,
il a envoyé
sur Terre, un hémisphère.
Ce gardien divin qui a la couleur
des fruits défendus
s'appelle mamba vert.
C'est un as
du camouflage doté d'un venin
on ne peut plus dissuasif
puisqu'il est mortel.
Babos connait
une recette toute simple.
Pour avoir
un mamba vert opérationnel,
laissez-le préchauffer
quelques instants au soleil matinal.
Quand son sang froid
a atteint la température ambiante,
il serait capable de détecter
tout déplacement suspect.
Quelques minutes plus tard
sa langue pourra capter
les odeurs qui flottent dans l'air.
Vous aurez ainsi
obtenu un mamba vert,
apte à tuer net n'importe
quel babouin amateur de figues.
Les babouins ne connaissent pas
la cuisine de Babos.
Ils se méfient instinctivement
de tout animal qui n'entre pas
dans la catégorie
des mangeurs de plantes immobiles.
Ne pouvant résister
0 savourer des figues mûres,
ils doivent à tout prix éloigner
cet animal bizarroïde qui prétend
se faire passer pour un végétal.
Si les plus petits
ne savent pas comment s'y prendre
pour éliminer ce rabat-joie
qu'est le mamba vert,
Alpha, lui, a mis au point
une méthode efficace et sans danger.
Une fois le serpent
tombé aux oubliettes,
il peut profiter
tranquillement des fruits défendus.
Ce qui devait arriver, arrive.
On ne badine pas
avec les injonctions divines.
Alpha s'en doutait, mais
comment résister à la tentation ?
Toutes ces figues juteuses.
Impossible.
Toute la troupe
se gave sans retenue.
La colère céleste
descend sur la Terre.
Pour chaque figue arrachée,
mangée ou gaspillée,
la colère de Babos se manifeste
de plus en plus
nettement dans la savane.
Effrayés par ce ciel menaçant,
les plus jeunes quittent
les extrémités des branches,
pour se réfugier près du tronc.
Sans se laisser intimider,
Alpha persévère dans l'interdit,
attisant encore
la fureur de Babos qui ouvre
maintenant les écluses des cieux.
Des averses diluviennes vont
s'abattre chaque jour au crépuscule
sur le Masai Mara et
ce pendant deux mois.
Babos a inventé
le calendrier et les saisons.
Première période,
la petite saison des pluies.
Il a plu pendant
tout novembre et décembre.
La petite saison
des pluies a fait son œuvre.
La rivière Talek se remet
à couler abondamment.
Elle coupe désormais
en deux la plaine verdoyante.
Ce qui va poser
quelques problèmes aux babouins.
Les babouins avaient l'habitude
de traverser
la rivière à pieds secs
pour chercher
de la nourriture.
Maintenant, ils vont
devoir trouver des gués.
Là encore, Alpha,
avec son expérience,
saura contourner la difficulté.
Finalement, la colère de Babos
aura été un mal pour un bien.
Les pluies ont fait jaillir de terre
de succulentes
pousses vertes toutes tendres.
Pas besoin de courir
par monts et par vaux
pour trouver de quoi manger.
Ce gain de temps est mis
à profit par les plus jeunes
pour inventer de nouveaux jeux.
Finalement, toute
la savane peut se réjouir
du courroux de Babos.
À force de gambader
avec insouciance
dans cette nature reverdie,
les babouins se sont éloignés
de leur quartier général, le figuier.
Un éléphant solitaire en profite
pour venir y cueillir
des branches bourgeonnantes.
Autour de l'arbre géant,
toute la gente herbivore
se régale d'herbes tendres.
Non loin de là,
des termites se félicitent
eux aussi des changements
survenus dans leur environnement.
Les averses ont tellement
bien ameublies le sol
qu'ils vont pouvoir construire
leur cathédrale de terre
120 000 ouvriers travaillant
plusieurs jours
sans relâche auront tôt fait
de modifier le profil de la savane
Les pluies ont complétement cessé
et la chaleur moite
commence à réduire
le débit de la rivière
qui devient quasi stagnante.
Le rat, locataire
du rez-de-jardin du figuier,
attendait ce moment depuis longtemps.
Il ne pleut plus, mais les fines
gouttelettes en suspens dans l'air,
transportent
des odeurs fortes alléchantes.
Une odeur de noisette
c'est sûr, mais...
ça sent aussi la viande,
il en aura le cœur net.
C'était bien ce qu'il espérait.
Une larve de scarabée xylophage.
Le bois mort
que consomme ces larves
leur donne en effet
un parfum de noisette.
Incisives tranchantes
et molaires râpeuses,
le rat a une dentition
tout à fait adapter
à un régime omnivore.
La larve une fois
broyée sera ingurgitée
en quelques minutes.
On pourrait croire que ce rat
est très à cheval sur la propreté
c'est plus subtile que ça.
Il est obligé de débarrasser
son pelage
de ce parfum de noisette
pour pouvoir repartir
à la chasse d'un bon nez.
Ce délicieux
parfum de noisette
vient aussi caresser
les narines d'Alpha
et de ses congénères
qui sont revenus près de leur figuier.
Ces branches mortes d'acacia
ont été ramollies par la pluie
ce qui permet
aux larves xylophages
de creuser de nouvelles galeries.
Un animal mobile
qui sent le fruit d'une plante immobile,
il n'en faut pas plus
pour qu'un végétarien se découvre
des gouts de carnivore.
Alpha ayant exercé
son droit de préséance,
les plus jeunes vont
pouvoir l'imiter à leur manière.
Hélas,
les jeunes doivent
abandonner la place sans délais
dès qu'un adulte la convoite.
Hiérarchie oblige.
Tout ce remue-ménage,
dérange sérieusement
d'autres occupants
de cette branche morte,
des fourmis.
Elles avaient installé
là leur pouponnière
et la nouvelle
circule qu'il va falloir
déménager de toute urgence.
Ces éclaireurs bien informés
par leurs antennes sont formels.
Il n'y a aucune galerie
de secours à l'intérieur de la branche
Le déménagement doit se faire
par l'extérieur
sous la garde des soldats
et en contournant, si possible,
ces objets velus non identifiés.
Les larves ne font pas partie
des fruits défendus par Babos.
Alors pourquoi
mamba vert rôde-t-il par ici ?
Rien à voir avec les babouins.
Le hasard l'a
amené dans les parages,
parce qu'il a repéré une proie,
un lézard.
Face à ce tueur d'élite
qu'est le mamba vert,
la seule chance de salut
est de sauter dans les herbes
et de s'y camoufler.
Cette ruse a brouillé les pistes.
Dérouté, le serpent
ne sait plus où chercher
et là, regardez bien.
Vous allez être témoin
d'un incroyable revirement de situation.
Le serpent meurt
lentement par asphyxie.
Babos vient de perdre
son plus précieux agent,
sa colère est terrible.
Il ordonne une grande
saison des pluies,
un déluge sans précèdent.
Quand les écluses
célestes se referment enfin,
les babouins ne peuvent que
constater l'étendue des dégâts.
L'eau a tout envahie.
La rivière Talek
est sortie de son lit
et s'étale dans
les plaines avoisinantes
Comme la terre
était déjà saturée d'eau,
l'eau glisse sur l'eau
et finit par revenir à la rivière.
Dans ces conditions,
il n'est plus envisageable
de chercher un gué
où un passage
étroit pour traverser
d'autant que cette
crue a fait apparaitre
dans la rivière
des créatures mobiles
et pas du tout végétariennes.
Pour passer sur
l'autre rive, une seule solution,
le grand saut.
À l'instar d'Alpha,
toute la troupe fait le grand saut
au risque de chuter
et de finir entre
les mâchoires des crocodiles.
Le problème avec
ces sauts de haut en bas,
c'est qu'on ne peut
plus revenir en arrière.
La rivière Talek est
désormais infranchissable.
Alpha et sa troupe devront donc
partir en quête
d'un nouvel arbre.
Hélas, on ne choisit pas
toujours son point de chute.
L'atterrissage dans
les acacias truffés d'épines
laisse de très mauvais souvenirs.
Cette épreuve de voltige
aurait-elle fait
tourner la tête des femelles ?
Postérieurs roses
et tuméfiés, regards langoureux,
pas de doute,
elles sont en chaleur
et ne cachent pas leur intérêt
pour les mâles adultes.
Alpha a déjà cédé
aux avances de celle-ci,
aux grands dam de celle-là.
Les accouplements sont brefs
mais très fréquents
chez les babouins.
Vous avez dit luxure ?
Babos décide de jouer
un mauvais tour à ses créatures.
Ils envoient sur Terre
sa collection de tiques.
De babouins en babouins, ces parasites
se répandent dans toute la tribu.
Même en se grattant
consciencieusement,
impossible
de s'en débarrasser,
il faut s'entraider.
Peu à peu l'épouillage mutuel
s'inscrit dans les relations sociales
de première importance.
Les plus hauts placés se font
épouiller par ceux de rang inférieur.
Comme ici, Alpha,
par une de ses compagnes.
Les femelles
toilettent leurs petits
et se toilettent entre elles
avec un plaisir évident.
Décidément, les babouins
savent tourner à leur avantage
toutes
les fourberies de Babos.
Maintenant qu'ils se retrouvent
sur l'autre berge de la rivière Talek,
ils vont devoir trouver
un arbre pour passer la nuit.
Pendant ce temps,
le figuier géant est le théâtre
d'une activité intense
comme chaque fois que
les babouins ne sont pas là.
Une colonie de fourmis
safari a installé un bivouac
dans le sol détrempé
au pied de l'arbre.
Une véritable armée
en campagne qui prépare un RAID.
Première trouvaille,
un excrément datant du dernier
passage de l'éléphant solitaire,
rien d'intéressant à première vue,
mais il faut creuser la question
pour parvenir
sous l'excrément.
Les fourmis safari savent que
sous une crotte d'herbivore
d'autres spécialistes de la vie
souterraines forent des galeries
pour approvisionner
leur cathédrale.
Le gang des fourmis
safari attaque les termites.
Les guerrières déposent
dans un lieu convenu d'avance
les cadavres
des termites.
Une fois toutes
les galeries nettoyées,
elles reprendront
la formation en cohorte
pour ramener le butin
jusqu'à leur bivouac.
On sait les fourmis capables
de porter quatre fois leur poids.
Les safaris cherchent
visiblement à battre des records.
Sans doute l'ardeur
militaire qui les anime.
À quelques
kilomètres de là,
sur l'autre rive
de la Talek,
la troupe d'Alpha
cherche un nouveau dortoir.
Elle peut
constater au passage
que les créatures
qui ont envahi la rivière
et qui n'entrent pas dans la catégorie
mangeurs des plantes immobiles,
ont une dentition
et une force
à vous faire froid dans le dos.
Voyant cela, Alpha prend
la sage décision de s'écarter
de ces eaux malfamées,
et d'aller prospecter dans la forêt.
Dans les sous-bois, les babouins
tombent sur un troupeau d'impalas.
Pour se défendre
des prédateurs,
ces vulnérables gazelles
se sont associés à des phacochères.
Ces derniers, très agressifs,
s'interposent si besoin, entre les impalas
et celui qui
prétendrait les attaquer.
Comme cette hyène,
les phacochères laissent
leurs cueillettes de plantes immobiles
pour former un barrage dissuasif
et renvoyer la hyène d'où elle vient.
Simple et efficace.
Du coup, Alpha se sent aussi
en sécurité dans cette clairière.
Reste à trouver un arbre.
Tous les arbres
se ressemblent ici
et aucun d'eux n'est assez
volumineux pour accueillir 40 babouins.
Une fois n'est pas coutume,
la troupe doit se disperser pour dormir.
Par sécurité,
les plus jeunes se sont
regroupés autour d'Alpha.
Ils peuvent jouer
sans crainte, se mettre d'accord
sur l'occupation du dortoir.
Chacun a fini
par trouver sa place.
Avant de s'endormir,
Alpha et les autres
mâles adultes repèrent
les positions des uns et
des autres dans la canopée.
La nuit,
on se perd de vue,
mais on garde
le contact par la voix.
Le lendemain, un babouin
plus matinal que les autres
réveille ceux qui dorment dans son arbre,
et les convainc de descendre.
C'est bien joli
de jouer les lève tôt,
mais que faire dans
cette brume matinale ?
Attendre
le réveil des autres.
Les derniers levés semblent pressés
d'explorer leur nouvel eldorado.
Grosso modo, la troupe
d'Alpha se débrouille bien.
Elle a su jusqu'à présent
résoudre tous les problèmes,
contourner les difficultés,
déjouer les pièges.
Elle peut espérer
maintenant vivre en paix.
Seulement, la rancune
de Babos est tenace.
Après la petite saison des pluies,
le grand déluge et les tiques,
il va maintenant semer
la zizanie dans la savane.
Quand il y a la bagarre dans l'air,
Romos répond toujours présent.
En face de lui, Molosse,
son frère aîné, sûr de sa force
et assoiffé de pouvoir.
Ses manœuvres d'intimidation
trahissent son ambition,
usurper
la place d'Alpha.
Alpha refuse de s'en mêler,
mais surveille ces rixes familiales.
C'est un pacifiste
doublé d'un fin stratège.
Ne voulant pas se battre,
il prend avec lui un petit,
à la fois pour protéger
celui-ci et s'en faire un bouclier.
Molosse a lancé
la première charge,
mais sans insister.
Chez les babouins, on préfère
la force de dissuasion à celle de frappe.
Romos s'est contenté d'esquiver
l'attaque et vient provoquer Alpha.
Alpha campe
sur sa neutralité.
Molosse, lui, a toujours
besoin de décharger son agressivité.
Il s'en prend
de nouveau à Romos.
Romos se rend bien compte
qu'il n'aura pas le dessus.
Il a deux ans
et moins de kilos que son frère.
Alors, il lui suggère
de faire alliance avec lui
contre d'autres
membres de la troupe,
histoire
de se défouler un peu.
Marché conclu.
Tous les babouins
préfèrent fuir ces deux têtes brûlées.
Il ne leur reste qu'à essayer de
défier à nouveau Alpha qui n'a pas bougé.
Allez, une bonne
petite castagne !
Alpha connaît
ces manigances.
Molosse a beau hausser les sourcils
et Romos, lui montrer les dents,
ses provocations
le laissent de marbre.
On n'apprend
décidément pas à un vieux singe
à faire des grimaces.
Il n'y aura donc pas
de troisième larron.
Du coup, Molosse jette une fois
de plus son dévolu sur Romos.
Molosse est le vainqueur.
C'est la victoire
de la force sur la ruse.
Romos qui a fait une chute, n'a plus
qu'à faire l'inventaire de ses blessures.
Un poignet broyé.
Plus question
de participer à une coalition
contre les plus jeunes.
La bajoue gauche déchirée.
Il lui faudra un certain temps
pour pouvoir mâcher normalement.
Heureusement, ce ne sont
que des blessures bénignes.
Par contre, il n'a plus aucune
chance d'évincer son frère.
Il devra désormais
se soumettre à son autorité.
Le revoici,
le frangin victorieux.
À voir comment il crane, il est
décidé à faire valoir sa supériorité.
Il existe une règle incontournable
dans la vie sociale des babouins,
un individu de statut
inférieur est tenu de présenter
son arrière-train
à un dominant
et d'accepter
d'être considéré.
C'est un peu vexant.
Avec ces histoires,
la troupe n'a pas encore pris
un seul repas
aujourd'hui.
Il est temps
qu'Alpha conduise les siens
vers un endroit
riche en pousses immobiles.
Contrairement à d'habitude, comme
s'il avait un mauvais pressentiment,
il décide de laisser les jeunes
dans la clairière du dortoir
pour partir
en éclaireur.
Les troupeaux de jeunes
mamans marchent dans les plaines
sous la conduite
de leur doyenne.
Alpha est rassuré.
Il sait que ces mangeurs
de plantes immobiles sont inoffensifs.
La troupe peut venir.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils fabriquent ?
Ils devraient être à l'orée du bois,
en train d'attendre un signe.
Sans doute, y a-t-il
un malentendu,
car de son côté,
tout son petit monde semble
attendre qu'il vienne les chercher.
Finalement, Molosse prend l'initiative
d'amener la troupe vers la prairie.
Alpha se doute que Molosse
ne va pas tarder à l'évincer.
Pour l'heure, les jeunes et les femelles
ne changent rien à leurs habitudes.
Ils rejoignent Alpha pour
la cueillette et le festin quotidien.
Alpha a beau
avoir de l'expérience,
il y a des choses
qui le laisse perplexe.
Ainsi,
le comportement de Molosse.
Depuis plusieurs jours,
il n'a qu'une idée en tête
devenir calife
à la place du calife.
Le voilà qui vient
montrer son arrière-train
pour manifester
sa soumission.
Méfiant, Alpha refuse
de se prêter à ce double jeu.
Les babouins vous le diront,
quand un babouin vous tourne le dos,
c'est qu'il
ne veut plus vous voir.
Le message est clair.
La vie politique est compliquée
chez les créatures de Babos.
Dominant, dominé,
la limite est floue.
Souvent chez
les jeunes mâles,
l'envie de prendre le pouvoir
est plus forte que tout.
Molosse a vaincu Alpha !
C'est la victoire
de la brutalité sur la sagesse.
Molosse est ravi
d'être arrivé à ses fins.
Pour asseoir
son autorité,
il n'hésite pas à faire régner
la terreur dans la troupe.
Timidement, les autres
adultes s'organisent,
et forment des alliances
pour lui tenir tête.
Seulement, devant
des arguments aussi pointus,
on perd un peu
de sa témérité.
Molosse se sent bien dans
sa peau de grand mâle adulte.
D'ailleurs, il songe déjà à goûter
aux privilèges réservés à son statut.
Il a ses chances,
car c'est un des seuls
qui soit encore présentable.
Les autres
ne sont pas beaux à voir.
Romos a toujours
son trou dans la bajoue.
Alpha est passablement
amoché par son combat.
Cet illustre inconnu
a été victime lui aussi du despote.
Août.
Il n'a pas plu
depuis deux mois.
Babos se tient
scrupuleusement à son calendrier.
C'est la grande
saison sèche.
Les herbivores n'ont plus
pour pâture que ces herbes jaunies.
Dans leurs sorties,
les babouins seront appelés
à rencontrer
un chasseur expert
dans cette savane
dorée, le guépard.
Le guépard s'approche rarement
des zèbres, qui ont l'habitude
de se défendre
à coup de sabot.
C'est peut-être pour cela que
les babouins restent parmi eux.
Les victimes
principales du guépard,
les gazelles de Thomson.
Du côté des chasseurs,
une femelle et
ses trois fils, déjà grands.
La mère chasse en solo
pour ses trois petits ogres.
En avançant face au vent,
elle est sûre de ne pas alerter
les gazelles qui ont
l'odorat très fin.
Le reste n'est qu'une
question de vélocité.
On sait que le guépard est champion
du monde dans cette discipline.
Grâce à ses narines
très échancrées
elle peut reprendre son souffle
tout en asphyxiant sa proie.
C'est l'heure du repas
pour les trois petits ogres.
À condition qu'ils
retrouvent leur mère
dans les hautes herbes.
Tiens, tiens !
Les babouins, Molosse en tête,
se dirigent vers le lieu du crime.
Les premiers arrivés
sont les guépards, mais Molosse,
toujours aussi agressif,
leur dispute leur butin.
Du jamais vu dans la savane,
une poignée des babouins qui
prétendent faire fuir quatre guépards.
Les guépards ne sont pas
prêts à lâcher le morceau.
Malgré les attaques répétées
des babouins, ils résistent.
Le combat s'équilibre,
mais dans un cafouillage absolu.
Finalement, la détermination
de Molosse a gagné la troupe.
Devant une telle
cohésion, les félins capitulent.
Dans la confusion,
le cadavre a été disséqué
puis dispersé partout.
Il va leur falloir glaner çà
et là, des morceaux de chair.
Molosse s'est octroyé
la part du lion,
le tronc de la gazelle.
Les autres n'ont qu'à bien
se tenir et se contenter des pattes.
Oui, les babouins
sont aussi carnivores.
On ne rate pas une occasion de manger
de la viande sans avoir à chasser.
Adieu la belle
harmonie voulue par Babos.
En attendant,
il y a des laissés pour compte,
les jeunes et les femelles
babouins d'un côté
et les guépards de l'autre.
Ces derniers iront tenter
leur chance plus loin.
En l'absence de pluie, les mangeurs
de plantes immobiles tondent les plaines.
Molosse et sa bande
décident de mettre fin
à une errance
qui dure depuis quatre mois.
Bonne nouvelle,
la rivière Talek
est revenue dans son lit.
Les babouins
vont pouvoir la retraverser
pour retrouver
leur cher grand figuier,
le plus bel
arbre de Masai Mara.
À l'approche du figuier,
la frénésie
l'emporte sur la discipline.
Chacun cherche
un raccourci
pour franchir les falaises
creusées par le dernier déluge.
Tous y arrivent bien.
Presque tous, sauf un.
Il faut pourtant faire vite,
car la nuit tombe autour du figuier
qui, depuis un an,
a eu le temps de faire ses fruits,
pour le bonheur de Molosse,
le premier arrivé.
Les autres
ne tarderont pas.
Finalement,
tout va encore très bien,
jusqu'à ce que...